sometimes it's wild to think that long
before there was a new call of duty game
every year
activision's big annual franchise was
tony hawk's pro skater
it's a series in which you only have to
worry about tying off each ludicrously
long combo before you
bail and lose hundreds of thousands of
points with the sounds of goldfinger and
rage against the machine burning to your
head you scour
each dense park in search of skates and
that mysterious secret tape
and as soon as you finally find them
it's time to restart the two minute
timer and jump back in for one last go
which you already told yourself was
three sessions prior the stimulating
trick system keeps you clawing for
larger numbers while the cleverly
crafted levels
lead you to new gaps lines and secrets
it's a special series that is infinitely
playable and tony hawk's pro skater 1
and 2
captures that nearly perfectly
tony hawk's pro skater 1 and 2 revamps
the levels and skaters of the first two
games though it borrows many
aspects from later titles as well while
the trick systems foundation stuck
through the entire series history
various trick types were added with each
new release tony hawk's pro skater 1 and
2 features
many of the best ones including reverts
and spine transfers and
thankfully it doesn't stray further than
underground's wall plants and grind in
manual transitions
this makes 1 and 2's trick system feel
complete as it focuses
on the best aspects of the series and
tony hawk's pro skater 1 and 2 plays
fantastically too
while you still control it the exact
same way you would the originals it
feels a lot less stiff
tricks are as exciting to pull off as
they've ever been but the speed of the
game moves faster
and the skater's animations are a lot
more fluid transitioning from grab
tricks and spins into a string of
manuals and then finishing with a set of
grind transitions
feels incredible it evokes the series
early days while also remaining engaging
and exciting when you're checking off
goals in 2020
levels have received makeovers and each
one looks absolutely stunning
whether you're skating on venice beach
or bombing it through the dilapidated
mall it's quite shocking to see these
classic stages with much more detail and
with much less fog than on the original
playstation the sunset on venice beach
hits with vibrant oranges and reds that
give a whole new mood to the oceanside
level while the maul
is overgrown with plants and plywood
barricaded stores
it almost looks post-apocalyptic i never
saw them all as abandoned or even run
down but this new take
along with many other new looks makes it
feel like you're experiencing a brand
new level even if the layout is the same
however loading into some of the parks
can take quite a bit of time
restarting your run something you'll
likely do a lot of can also take up to 5
seconds in some instances the original
games
were quite snappy and you were able to
restart your run quickly if you weren't
happy with how your session was going
five seconds isn't a big deal and didn't
impede my enjoyment too much but when
the rest of the game
nails the tony hawk pro skater
experience it's hard not to notice the
smallest of divergences
many of the original games goals are
present with a few added to beef up the
checklists
once you complete a goal however it's
completed for every skater in the
original games each skater had their own
career to play through giving you the
option to complete all of the goals with
every playable skater i can still go and
collect stat points for every character
but it can feel oddly empty without
these objectives
that said you're not left without stuff
to do once you've finished your first
playthrough tony hawk's pro skater 1 and
2 introduces a whole slate of challenges
that have you completing specific feats
these include performing different
combos and various other tasks
tony hawk pro skater's core mechanics
are engaging enough to be the sole
reason you play but these challenges
give you compelling new goals to chase
as you try to best your top scores
the soundtrack also boasts music fit for
a tony hawk's pro skater game
many of the original tracks return for
one and two but a lot of new music is
also included
these all fit in with the classic tracks
and if it wasn't for their respective
release dates
it's easy to imagine them on the
original soundtrack it's an eclectic
mix of hip-hop and punk and reminds me
of why tony hawk's pro skater is
remembered for its music
as much as its mechanics
tony hawk pro skater one and two's
create a park mode lets you do exactly
as it says and it's a pretty extensive
and easy to use tool for creating your
own levels
sharing levels with other players is
also possible and there are already a
number of custom parks that show off
both quality and silliness
it's a far more enjoyable mode than it
ever was in its early days and i'm
really excited to see what the community
creates
as for its multiplayer tony hawk pro
skater 1 and 2 offers both local
and online versus modes a lot of the
game types take after the original
game's multiplayer too
horse also returns and while it's mostly
a great time
some infrequent frame dropping can occur
it's a bit surprising since you take
turns trying to outdo your friend's
score and it doesn't feel particularly
demanding
even more surprising is the fact that
the split screen modes don't come with
these same performance issues
the online multiplayer on the other hand
runs very well as it rotates through
various modes in a lobby
it's an exciting way to hang out with
friends skate and compete for the
highest score
because it nails so much about that
original tony hawk experience
it's really hard to be mad at pro skater
1 and 2 for any
of its downsides the load times aren't
enough to keep you away from the
plethora of satisfying combos and the
lack of level goals for every skater
isn't enough to keep you from jumping
back in with a new character
playing through the newly remade levels
is immensely enjoyable
and that on its own is enough to call
tony hawk's pro skater 1 and 2 a success
however smart additions and the engaging
challenge system
make it an experience that's more than
just a brief skate through tony hawk's
past
[Music]
you